now it was so fast because it was so
quick uh just me looking at him like to
me it's just like wow
two and eight news now investigators
exclusive that limo driver was the one
behind the wheel minutes after a beating
at a Las Vegas strip nightclub
prosecutors say two NFL players
including New Orleans Saint Alvin Kamara
are in this car a news now investigator
David Charles first with that video
tonight that limousine driver tells us
what He remembers
[Music]
a dash camera rolls as this SUV leaves
the Cromwell on the Las Vegas Strip
minutes earlier a camera catches New
Orleans Saints running back Alvin Kamara
now Cincinnati Bengals cornerback Chris
lemons and two other men allegedly
beating a man outside a nightclub
leading to felony charges so had you
driven them to Dre's yes yep the night
of yeah the man behind the wheel is 30
year old Jordan Morrison when you're
picking them up do you have any idea
what had just happened minutes before
um based based on how they were coming
into the View Garden though something
did happen I said you know what until
they start talking in the vehicle video
the 8 news now investigators obtained
show the group rushing into the SUV I
kind of figured oh they got into some
trouble and they're just trying to get
away from it
Morrison stone-faced in the driver's
seat says he doesn't remember hearing
what prosecutors call an admission
what was your reaction when you saw that
video honestly it just it kind of
brought back what they were saying
because when I was driving I didn't know
what they were saying I was just so
tired out of it I got maybe I was on
fumes Morrison no longer works for the
limousine company he says he'd like to
believe the people he was driving around
in the days before this recording were
not the ones he saw in this video I was
shocked because I didn't really see you
know the guy that was treating me like
you know really well to do something
like that but the one thing I always
want to say is there's always two sides
of the story Metro Police subpoenaed
this dash cam footage shortly after the
beating a grand jury saw it and then
indicted Kamara lemons and those two
other men including the one you see
there in the front seat all four are due
in court Thursday morning I'm David
charns eight news now